este combatiente cubre la letra Z uno de
los símbolos del ejército de Vladimir
Putin en su lugar una viñeta que
representa el cuerpo de voluntarios
rusos un grupo ferozmente opuesto al
kremlin y que habría participado en la
incursión de virgoroth la más grave en
el territorio ruso desde el inicio de la
guerra en dos días varias localidades de
belgorón han sido atacadas por boca del
portavoz del Ministerio de defensa ruso
Moscú afirma que la ofensiva ha
terminado y acusa directamente a kiev
durante la operación antiterrorista
gracias a los ataques aéreos y de
artillería y a la acción de las unidades
de defensa fronteriza del distrito
militar occidental las formaciones
nacionalistas ucranianas fueron
bloqueadas y aplastadas
Igor con nation kof añade que en este
contraataque murieron 70 ucranianos esta
información es imposible de verificar el
gobierno de kiev niega cualquier
implicación en esta incursión sin
embargo la operación Fue reivindicada en
un canal de Telegram que se presenta
como perteneciente a un grupo de rusos
que luchan en el bando ucraniano
es hora de poner fin a la Dictadura del
kremlin Muchas gracias a todos los que
nos apoyan y nos envían donativos su
apoyo es lo que nos recuerda cada día
Nuestro objetivo final en la plaza Roja
de Moscú sean valientes y no tengan
miedo porque volvemos a casa Rusia será
libre
el lunes Rusia declaró una operación
antiterrorista en la región de belgorón
fronteriza con Ucrania una medida que
dio a las autoridades más poderes para
llevar a cabo operaciones armadas o
evacuar a la población